hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing three new
details revealed about the upcoming
Harry Potter reboot with the news
earlier this month that a new Harry
Potter shows on the horizon the Harry
Potter fandom has been abuzz with
excitement as new details about the show
are slowly unveiled since the
announcement fans have been eagerly
awaiting news about the new adaptation
and now three major updates have been
released offering a small glimpse into
what we can expect from the series from
casting decisions to the budget we'll
dive into these exciting new details and
what they could mean for the World of
Harry Potter more spin-offs Warner CEO
Casey blois recently made a statement
that a sent Harry Potter fans into a
frenzy speaking at a press conference
boys discussed the upcoming HBO reboot
of the blood franchise and hinted at the
potential for other spin-offs after the
new series has begun production subtly
alluding to the fact that a deal had
been struck with rolling bloy's
statement has sparked speculation about
what these spin-offs could be and
whether they will be connected to the
original Harry Potter storyline or
explore new territory in the Wizarding
World while boys did not provide any
concrete details about the potential
spin-offs he did Express excitement
about the possibilities Harry Potter is
such a red chamber of the universe and
we are thrilled to have the opportunity
to explore it further he said we have
some exciting ideas in the works and
can't wait to share them with fans while
I welcome the idea of a reboot I can't
help but wonder what these spin-offs are
going to be in my opinion spin-offs
should be the main focus of today not
tomorrow but if we're going to get both
then I'm not going to complain budget I
think you'll be delighted to hear that
as far as the reboot no expenses will be
spared according to sources HBO has
allocated a whopping 250 million dollars
for the production of the new series
this budget even higher than HBO's House
of the Dragon which reportedly cost
between 150 and 200 million for its
first 10 episodes
with the budget this launch I think we
can expect the new Harry Potter series
to be a visual spectacle leveraging this
immense sum of money showrunners will be
able to create stunning visual effects
and production designs bringing the
Magical World of Harry Potter to life in
a new way that has never been seen
before that is all while attracting top
tier talent for the cast and crew
budgets are important for television
series because it often determines the
quality of the production and I think
that with 250 million they should be
able to make this work casting casting
for the reboot of the Harry Potter
series is already underway and fans are
eagerly awaiting news of who will be
playing their favorite characters I've
even made a few casting videos one thing
is for certain however author JK Rowling
will have the final say on all casting
decisions Rowling has been involved in
the casting process for all the previous
Harry Potter films and spin-offs and her
involvement in the HBO reboot is no
different she's been vocal about her
dedication to ensuring that the
characters are portrayed accurately but
the right amount of depth and Nuance her
commitment to staying true to the
characters and their stories has been a
Hallmark of the franchise and her
involvement in the HBO reboot is a clear
indication that the network is dedicated
to delivering a high quality viewing
experience for fans and that's it for
this video what do you think of these
updates let me know down in the comment
section below also be sure to leave your
video requests down there so they can
make the content that you all want until
next time remember there is plenty to be
learned even from a bad teacher what not
to do how not to be